qué función cuadrática alcanza su máximo
en el número más pequeño y nos dan estas
tres funciones empecemos con lo más
fácil que sería hdx es la más fácil
porque aquí tengo la gráfica y entonces
visualmente puedo encontrar el máximo
que parece estar en este punto aquí y
parece valer menos 1 de modo que el
máximo de hd x el máximo
thx
es igual a menos 1
vemos uno bien que deje de equis en este
caso me están dando la tabla y aquí
puedo notar inspeccionando la tabla que
el valor máximo es 5 por lo tanto el
máximo el máximo de gx de x es
simplemente 5 ahora ese x me dieron este
polinomio de grado 2 que de hecho es la
definición de una función cuadrática así
que en este caso lo más sencillo es
completar el cuadrado vamos a ver cómo
se hace tengo que
fx fx es igual a menos x al cuadrado más
6x menos 1
voy a factorizar este menos porque no me
gusta tenerlo allí y esto se convierte
en menos x al cuadrado menos 6 x
más
ahora bien lo que quiero hacer es sumar
un número de modo que x al cuadrado
menos 6 x más ese número sea un cuadrado
perfecto así que tengo que sumar una
constante y la constante va a ser la
mitad del coeficiente de la x al
cuadrado en este caso el coeficiente de
la x es menos 6 por lo tanto su mitad es
menos 3 y al cuadrado me daría 9 así que
voy a sumar 9 pero como no quiero
cambiar el valor de esta expresión de fx
también voy a restar un 9
de modo que efectivamente lo que hice
sumó un cero por lo tanto el valor no
cambia ahora quizás estén preguntando
bueno y para que hiciste eso pues la
razón es que ahora este cacho de aquí x
al cuadrado menos 6 x más 9 ahora es un
cuadrado perfecto de modo que toda esta
expresión es lo mismo que
esto es lo mismo que menos ya tengo s
menos
- x al cuadrado menos 6 x más 9 es lo
mismo que x menos 3 al cuadrado y menos
9 menos 9 más 1 es menos 8 ahora
simplemente puede distribuir al menos y
obtengo menos x 3 al cuadrado más 8
ahora para encontrar el máximo de esta
expresión lo que tengo que hacer es
analizar este factor que es el variable
x menos 3 al cuadrado siempre va a ser
un número no negativo porque es un
cuadrado así que puede ser mayor o igual
a 0 y después tengo que considerar este
- que está aquí este menos hace que este
número que era no negativo ahora sea en
total considerando al menos un número no
positivo de modo que siempre le estoy
restando algo a 8 por lo tanto esta
expresión alcanzará su máximo cuando le
reste lo menos posible al 8
y eso sucede cuando x es igual a 3
porque entonces este número de aquí es
de modo que esto me quedaría menos 08 y
ese va a ser el valor máximo así que el
máximo
el máximo de fx
es igual a 8 de donde la función
cuadrática que alcanza a su máximo en el
número más pequeño es precisamente hdx